في المانيا يبدو ان ما اطل براسه امس هو
فقط راس شبح النازيه اما الجذور في عميقه
على غير المتوقع عمليات الاعتقال التي
انطلقت لتفكيك مجموعه من اقصى اليمين كان
هدفها الانقلاب على الدوله تتواصل تضاعف
عدد من يخدعون للتحقيق ليتخطى 50 في رقم
بعيد عن ان يكون نهائيا لكن اخطر ما في
العمليه تكشفه نياق تايمز مخطط الانقلاب
لم يكن يقتصر فقط على اقتحام مقر البرلمان
بل اغتيال راس الدوله
مع عدد من المشرعين الذين تصفاهم المجموعه
الانقلابيه بالاعداء تقرير الصحيفه
الامريكيه اشار ايضا الى ان المخطط كان
يهدف الى تخريب شبكه الكهرباء لتسهيل
عمليه الانقلاب وان عناصر المجموعه اشترى
بالفعل هواتف وتعمل بالاقمار الصناعيه
لضمان بقاء التواصل بينهم خلال مراحل
تنفيذ الانقلاب المجمع
اما الجانب الذي يبعث على الاطمئنان حتى
الان فهو سقوط الراس المدبر الامير هنري
الثالث عشر الذي كان يريد ان ينصب نفسه
رئيسا جديدا للبلاد في حال نجاح الانقلاب
المتهم الرئيسي في القضيه ينحدر من عائله
رئيس الملكيه الالمانيه ويبلغ من العمر 71
عاما وهو رجل اعمال النشطه في مجال
العقارات ومقيم في مدينه فرانكفورت في وسط
المانيا وكان سيتم في حال نجاح الانقلاب
اعلان حكومه جديده في ظل قيادته وتشكيل
جيش الماني جديد
حتى الان من غير الواضح مدى قدره المجموعه
على تنفيذ مخططها لكن الاكيده ان الضخامه
عدد المشتبه بهم ووجود حديثا عن اتصالات
مع روسيا او غيرها يشيء بان المحاوله لم
تكن لهوا وانا نازيه التي يتبرا منها
الالمان منذ عقود لم تموت